as a therapist my job is to help them be
the best version of themself as a
teacher i was an academic at fordham
university in cornell
it's to help those students be the best
version of themselves as a manager i
realized that that it wasn't about me it
was about helping my people be as good
as they could be
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders today we're
going to be talking about influence and
impact meet bill berman
bill has 30 plus years of experience as
an executive coach senior line manager
clinician and academic he has advised
executives from multiple industries
including financial services
pharmaceuticals publishing and
technology companies and worked with
ceos and teams at the c-suite managing
director and general function management
levels
bill started his own software company in
1994 to track health care outcomes which
he subsequently sold to an enterprise
healthcare information system company
he is the author of more than 50
research articles and books including
influence and impact discover and excel
at what your organization needs from you
the most
bill berman welcome to 20 minute leaders
thank you so much for joining me today
how are you i'm well thanks thanks for
having me on the show
well you know you sort of do what i'm
trying to do on the show you're working
on
leadership and you're working on
influence and you're working on impact
which are really the main questions that
i'm trying to uncover in this show you
know what makes a leader a good leader
what makes an influencer a good
influencer making a positive impact not
just on the world that we all like to
try to do but also internally in an
organization so thank you very much for
joining me today great looking forward
to it
bill why dedicate your career and so
much of your time right now to
uncovering this question of influence
and
impact well you know um i've done a
number of things i don't have one of
those straight line careers i started
life as a clinical psychologist and then
started a software company and that's an
interesting transition that i
um and then when i then i sold my
software company to another software
company and then when i left there i
started doing executive coaching
and
it
during the course of that time it became
very clear to me both in the management
work that i did and
and
as a coach
that a lot of times people think they're
focused on the right things
and they're probably are about 70
percent of the time
but they're not 100 focused on the right
things so they're
i find they often are doing what's
either more comfortable for them
or
what they're more familiar with or
they're doing what they wish the job was
or they're not doing what they what the
part of the job that makes them anxious
so there are all these reasons
underlying reasons why people don't do
it but they're off the mark
and as a result
they're
not able to have the impact that they
want to have because they're they're not
they're focused on what their needs are
rather than what the needs of their
manager are what the needs of their
stakeholders are what the needs of their
their company
is right and so but where where where
did the curiosity for this
uh stem from because um you know i'm a
clinical psychologist entrepreneur
working companies and elves and then
turning to be an executive coach what
makes somebody become an executive coach
you know there are a lot of people who
go into executive coaching um for me
my whole life has my whole adult life
has been about
helping other people be the best version
of themselves
so as a therapist my job is to help them
be the best version of themself as a
teacher i was an academic at fordham
university in cornell
it's to help those students be the best
version of themselves as a manager i
realized that that it wasn't about me it
was about helping my people be as good
as they could be right i didn't i wasn't
the one who was meeting with clients and
and implementing software systems it was
my people who were doing it so i had to
get the best out of them so all along
the way it's been about helping people
be what they're capable of being
um right so that's and and that's it's
just been sort of the driving force in
my life it probably comes let me ask you
sorry
let me ask you a a is a question that
may sound trivial but i think it's it's
a crucial one to really understand why
is this not easy why isn't it
straightforward if i'm in a leadership
position or if you even if i'm not you
know in the r in a i was an officer in
the military and and they tell us that
we have to command 360 degrees we we
don't only make an impact on those
you know below us in command but also
those are horizontal and above why isn't
it a natural thing for us to be able to
do well
there are two reasons one is emotions
you know our emotions get a
drive our behavior sometimes with our
knowledge sometimes without our
knowledge
but fear anxiety desire
passion all of those things affect how
we behave
and if we're not careful if we're not
watching that it'll take us down
sometimes down the wrong road
the other reason why people um don't get
it right is that
they're not looking in the right place
they're not agile they're not flexible
so
what we talk about in the book is that
there are two things you have to do to
to have influence and impact number one
you have to know what your job is and do
it on a regular basis and the second is
you have to understand what the culture
is of the organization and you have to
adapt to that culture because that's the
other reason why people get in trouble
is they come with a certain style
with a certain approach and they don't
think they need to adapt to the
organization they're in
but it's organizations have strong
cultures just like countries have
cultures and ethnicities have cultures
and if you're not attentive to those
they're going to make it's going to make
it very difficult for you
right i i i can i can definitely you
know see that and see how that how that
translates to myself and so you're
working with with some remarkable people
and you know in all sorts of industries
and and i'm looking at myself now and a
lot of my peers that may be listening
here you know the young entrepreneurs
that are you know we're on our journey
whether we're engineers a small piece of
the puzzle or whether we're you know in
managerial positions what are some
things that we should be keeping in mind
from your
from your insights especially looking at
influence and impact
that we can employ
to be better leaders 360 degrees
so
the most important piece of being a
leader is remembering that it's not
about you
right it's it's it and it's not and
that's where people get in trouble a lot
of the time
fundamentally you are there
you were there because
of your expertise you were there because
you're able to execute on a regular
basis but as a leader
you're there fundamentally because you
can help other people be successful
right if i'm
you've seen this in the military if
you're
you can't be successful if the team
around you isn't doing their job right
right it's your job to make sure they're
going to the right places they're
they're doing what they need to do
and in today's world
most business settings you don't
influence because you're saying to
people you have to do this it's not the
military anymore you're say it's it it's
all based on collaboration and influence
um i can't tell you how many people i
work with
where
they the person who
they report to
doesn't actually control what they do
and the people who
want them to do things
aren't really involved in what they
aren't aren't their direct line managers
so for example i had a uh
i was
i was coaching uh the general manager of
a of a group
and the entire sales force didn't report
to him
so he was responsible for the finances
but there was a central sales
organization and he
and all of the sales people reported up
to that person so their incentive comp
wasn't done by him it was done by the
salesperson so it was so he had to
influence people to sell what he wanted
them to sell
so there and i can give you countless
examples of situations like that where
you just don't have the level of
authority that you you had in the 20th
century
that that makes lots i'd love to hear a
few more examples because i think these
are obviously then even if they don't
translate one to one to my situation or
to other situations we make we very
quickly make parallels to how we're what
things are going wrong in our
organizations and how we can improve on
them so i'd love to hear a few more
so i was working with a woman who was in
reliability engineering so she had a
team of about 20 people
and their job was to make sure that the
software in that people were running in
the organization was running efficiently
and effectively
and
but she thought her she defined her job
as i'm only going to work on those ones
that i think
that we can have the biggest impact on
what she didn't understand was that she
got a new boss she got a new manager and
a new manager's manager and they wanted
a much more sort of open collaborative
shared approach to this so she they
wanted her and her team to help people
even if it wasn't going to be the
biggest impact
and
she didn't communicate that so what we
did in the coaching was i really helped
her think about this as you're there to
meet the needs of your customers just
like i'm here to meet the needs of my
customers that doesn't mean you always
do what they tell you because sometimes
they don't know exactly what they need
but it means that you understand what
they want and you and you're empathic
with what they want and you
give them the message that you're there
to be helpful to them
that's when they're going to be happy
that's when they're going to be
satisfied
right how do
entrepreneurs in your opinion have the
capacity or or what tools do they have
their disposal to understand when
something is not going right when their
influence is not correct or is not is
not as strong as it can be or whether
the impact that they're having is not as
large as it can as it can be
how do how can we gauge this in our own
lives
i think you know fundamentally
self-awareness is the most important
skill
a leader can have if you don't
understand
how you're feeling what you're doing and
what impact it's having on others
you're going to get in trouble all the
time
and so
so being aware of that is really
critically important having
other people around you that you trust
who can tell you
what kind of impact you're having is
critically important as well
you know your spouse almost always
or your partner almost always knows
what's going on with you so using them
as a resource can be really helpful too
so do they do you find sometimes that
these things may translate also though
to the two personal lives that if we're
having trouble
influencing and making a positive impact
in our professional life that may also
have a translation in our personal lives
and and that makes it harder to gauge
um
yes so people do act differently in one
setting than the other but particularly
when they start to
what i call derail when they start to
get themselves in a little bit of
trouble
those often look the same whether it's
personal social or at work
um i think that makes it easier if
you're if you're self-aware if you know
yourself
you're going to be able to recognize
that wherever you are more quickly
and we all have characteristic patterns
it's not like you have to keep learning
it over and over and over
people get you know people struggle in
the same ways um you know when we get
when we get stressed
um when we're feeling either feeling our
oats or feeling overwhelmed we tend to
fall back on old patterns it's just
that's just human nature right and and
so knowing what those patterns are
knowing what those those old habits are
is really going to help you avoid them
and avoid getting in trouble with them
how do you work with with the people
that are that are approaching you or the
organizations that you work with and
what is this sort of this format of
executive coaching
you know obviously i think that it
probably every person in the world can
you can use some some great coaching
and a and how does it actually work
you know in many ways it follows a lot
of the format of the book so the first
thing i do with people when i when i get
to know them is i learn about them i
talk to them i talk to their manager i
talk to their stakeholders
i talk to i learn about the company that
they work for and i learn about the part
if they're if they're not the ceo or
c-suite i learn about the division
they're in
and so i get to understand the context
that they operate in
right
and then
a fundamental part of my job is to go
back to those people to my client and
say
here's where i think you're blowing the
doors off it and here's what i think you
can do that will make you even more
successful i try not to spend a lot of
time telling people what they're
screwing up unless they're really
screwing up
but
helping them see what will make them
most effective helping them see what
their manager really needs from them
what their customers need from them what
their stakeholders need from them and
helping them deliver on those things
both what the job is and how you do the
job
that's really that's that's my job and i
collect the data
and then i start working with them and
give them tools and techniques to to
find ways to
to make a change
once they do all that stuff then they
can start solving other problems for
people they can step up um they become
you can start becoming a leader among
your peers
somebody people will listen to
fundamentally you want people
to follow you you want them to want to
do what you want to do it's not leading
these days really it's building
followership that's the critical element
what are some things you've observed in
you know in the greater general sense
that may not be so trivial to me as i
think now about building follower base
about about building the impact that i
can the influence that i can have what
are some non-trivial things that you've
learned from you know the various case
studies that that you've gotten to
experience and obviously from the most
recent book that you can share with me
you know
i have a my older son who's an adult now
he had when he was in 11th grade he had
a teacher
who was incredibly tough on him
he but he his message to him was i know
you can do this i know you can do this
really well he said
don't mail it in to me
don't send me stuff that's not as good
as you can possibly do so he was tough
on him but he believed in him
and i think that i see that again and
again and again it's not a matter of
whether you're tough or lacks it's not
about being nice to your people
but it's about
believing in them and believing that
they have the capability that that's
incredible
how do we show to people that we that we
believe in in their ability because i'm
guessing it's not just the words that we
may use to to encourage that because it
has there has to be something that's
unheard or unseen that can also give
that impression and can be just as
powerful
you know
people say that you know eighty percent
of communication is non-verbal
um i don't know if the number is right
or not but your tone of voice your
facial expression
the words that you use
all communicate what you think of the
person that you're talking to
i can say
why'd you do it that way
or i can say why'd you do it that way
right very different message to you
um
you know and clearly you'd rather have
the first one
or you can and you can say
you know you could have done better than
this or you can say
you could have done better than this
same words but you different tone and
it's that tone oftentimes that gives the
gives away what you really think
so you got to be careful about small
things like the words you choose the
tone you have
the eye contact you make um
the posture you have you've got to watch
your non-verbal language because that
gives you away a lot of the time
i'm i'm i'm i'm going to need to spend
some time to reflect on what you just
heard because i think it's it's
something that's a you know remarkably
important here this idea that it's it's
not about you know being nice or not
being nice it's
it's it's about the belief right and and
people want to feel empowered people
want to feel trusted and having that
that that power
and autonomy to go and and do things
and fail but but fail and learn to
eventually succeed and and this is
definitely something bill that i'm going
to be taking to my own journey and so
i'm already very very thankful for this
uh and so
bill i i want to spend the last few
minutes and understanding you a little
bit better sure reflecting now
you know on your leadership did you
learn some things about yourself and
you're looking back at your past lives
and your past careers now that you've
been working in executive coaching
things that maybe surprised you or that
you know made you reflect
absolutely i've been learning
i'm always learning about myself um i
learned a long time ago that
that i can that i have to manage
my workflow very carefully because i get
excited about new ideas and new things
and i'll say yes to those things and
then run out of time
and so i'm always having to take a step
back and say do you really have time for
this is this the most important thing
you can be doing
um you know what is what's the
opportunity cost of doing this other
thing so i'm and i'm it never goes away
for me i'm always having to finding
myself in a situation where i'm a little
over committed where i'm not as focused
as i need to be and i have to pull back
so it's you know it it those things
don't go away i'm always going to be
excited by a new idea i just have to
manage that more carefully
bill i really want to thank you for
spending this time with me it was uh
remarkably important for me to hear and
i'm sure for so many others because i
think that some of the things here while
they me
seem trivial to some people i think that
they have they have a lot of depth
because they translate to the everyday
things that we do whether it's our tone
our choice of words our intonation and
the eye contact that we make and and i
love the fact that you're thinking about
it you're not we're not trying to be you
force yourself as leaders but we want to
build a follower base and we want to be
people the people we want to be a person
that people want to follow and that's
obviously 360 degrees in the
organization so bill thank you very very
much for this i i really appreciate your
time michael thank you for having me on
i was a very enjoyable interview so i'm
looking forward to seeing you thanks
bye-bye take care
[Music]